هذا الخبر العاجل طبعا نقل عن المراسلات
الجزيره ليقول بان رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيليه هيرتز هيلفي يعقد جلسه تقييم
امنيه مع القياده العسكريه نجوان ماذا عن
هذا هذه الجلسه هل انتهت هل رشح مضمونها
او اي معلومات عنها
لا هي جلسه مستمره في هذه الاثناء يعقدها
رئيس هيئه اركان
مع كبار قياده الجيش حول العمليات الاخيره
التي ينفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي والغارات
التي يشنها في قطاع غزه ولكن ايضا
لتلقي معلومات اضافيه
ولاحاطه رئيس هيئه الاركان باهداف ربما
يخطط الجيش ليواصل
عليها اذا هي حاله من الانعقاد المستمر
للمشاورات
ولجلسات التقييم الامنيه التي تعقد في
اسرائيل على مستويات عده مستويات على
المستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى الامني
والمستوى العسكري ستكون هناك ايضا بحسب
المعلومات التي وصلتنا قبل قليل جلسه اخرى
سيعقدها رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
كجلسه مشاورات امنيه مع رئيس وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
وهذه ايضا جلسات متكرره لكن من غير الواضح
بعد متى ستعقد هذه الجلسه اليوم لا سيما
وانه يوم السبت وفي العاده
ينتظر حتى ساعات المساء بعد خروج السبت
لتبدا مثل هذه الجلسات لكن في حاله التي
تعتبرها اسرائيل حاليا حاله طوارئ وحاله
حرب قد يتم عقد هذه الجلسه في الساعات
القريبه المقبله هذه الجلسات مستمره منذ
بدء المعركه راينا عده جلسات جلسات
للمشاورات الامنيه التي عقدها بنيامين
نتنياهو ولكن في كل مره وفي نفس الجلسه
خاصه في جلسه يوم امس وهذا اليوم كان يدور
الحديث بنفس الوقت على ان هذه الجلسات
تبحث من جهه
استمرار هذه العمليات وهذه المواجهه مع
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي لا سيما في ظل
توصيات واضحه من الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بضروره وقف هذه العمليه في
هذا الوقت من منطلق او على اعتبار انها
حققت من وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه الاهداف
التي حددت لهذه العمليه في البدايه وعلى
اعتبار ايضا انها حققت
الانجازات التي يمكن ان ينجزها الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه هذا من جهه توصيات امنيه
عسكريه لكن على المستوى السياسي ايضا هناك
عده توصيات من مسؤولين سياسيين بضروره
السعي لوقف هذه العمليه في هذه المرحله كي
لا يفقد كليا بنيامين نتنياهو السيطره على
نهايه هذه المعركه وشكلها وهذا ما بدا
يظهر عمليا لان
المركزي الذي يطرح حاليا في اسرائيل هو ما
هي ما هو الهدف من استمرار هذه المعركه
حتى ان الاهداف العسكريه غير واضحه ما
الذي
تقوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه بفعله وما الذي
تريد ايضا تحقيقه والى متى بطبيعه الحال
ستستمر هذه المعركه لاسيما وان اسرائيل
ارادت ان تحصر هذه المعركه في استهداف
مواقع لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وكانت هناك
اشاره واضحه
سربت عن مسؤولين امنيين يشاركون في هذه
الجلسات بان الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه
استنفذت هذه المواقع وهذه الاهداف التي
تحدد ولذلك يقوم الجيش
بشنغارات على نفس المواقع بين الحين
والاخر لكن ايضا هناك نوع من الحديث في
نفس المحادثات عن بحث مقترحات لوقف اطلاق
النار كان هناك في ليله امس مقترح مصري
وصف في بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بانه اقرب للموقف الاسرائيلي من مقترحات
سابقه تم عرضها على الجانبين اسرائيل لم
تعطي الرد او بشكل عام للجانب المصري عن
هذا المقترح كانت هناك تسريبات بين الحين
والاخر صباح هذا اليوم بان اسرائيل توافق
على المقترح على البنود العريضه لمقترح
وقف اطلاق النار الذي ياتي من القاهره
لكنها تعترض وبشكل مطلق على الشروط التي
تضعها حركه حماس وهي وقف سياسه الاغتيالات
او تحرير جثمان الشهيد الاسير خضر عدنان
اذا هي هو تماما الموقف الاول بالنسبه
لاسرائيل الذي تحدثت عنه منذ عده ايام بان
وقف اطلاق النار سيكون غير مشروط غير ملزم
وهي ربما كما قال العديد من المحللين
السياسيين في اسرائيل ان نتنياهو في هذه
المرحله يفضل اتفاق غير مكتوب صيغه
توافقيه عنوانها الهدوء يقابل بهدوء والا
يكون هناك اتفاق مكتوب ملزم بالنسبه
لاسرائيل بالمناسبه حتى لما كانت عندما
كانت اسرائيل تتوصل الى اتفاق مكتوب ويتم
بالفعل الالتزام ببعض الشروط لم تكن يعني
تلتزم بهذه الشروط والان هي حتى تريد ان
تتجنب ذلك اولا لان هناك عده وزراء في
حكومه نتنياهو من اقصى اليمين المتطرف
يضغطون عليه بعدم الردوق كما يصفونه او
الاذعان لحركات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعليه
سيكون من الصعب على نتنياهو ان يعلن بانه
وافق على مثل هذه الشروط صحيفه اريت كانت
قد انه ربما قد توافق اسرائيل على وقف
سياسه الاغتيالات وهذا نقلا عن احد
المسؤولين السياسيين في اسرائيل ولكن ليس
ضمن شروط اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار قد توافق
على ذلك مقابل الهدوء مقابل وقف حركات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باطلاق الصواريخ
ولكنها لن تلتزم ابدا بانها لن تعود الى
هذه السياسه وهذه السياسه تتبعها اسرائيل
منذ سنوات عده ضد الفلسطينيين في داخل
فلسطين ولكن ايضا في ضد شخصيات اخرى من
خارج فلسطين عبد القادر